boom boom the sculpture of god yeah
that's a good one yeah the
the first the first reaction the first
thought that i had when i came across
this picture was during my
entrance to stream entry on my second
retreat so i was meditating for
uh at agonica retreat 12 hours a day on
the 10th day the last
sit on the 10th date i was like i knew
something was happening
i just knew it was happening i was like
i have to sit through this sit
and however long it takes i'm going to
stay there by myself even after the
going card discourse
if i have to i just knew that i had to
break through something here i could
feel it
so i was sitting there after like three
hours i could see this image sort of
emerging
just from the distance at first it was
very small it looks almost exactly like
this at first it was very small
and then it became bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
that's when i was already sort of doing
self-inquiry
sort of abiding in the awareness phase
that's what allows this manifest
because i was already pulling away from
the franking entity from the
meditator entity even
and this thing emerged and i was like
the first reaction i had was like holy
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] creepy
it's creepy because first of all it's so
familiar it's almost like
that's it's almost like that's home or
like that that's always been me
at the same time it's it's extremely
alien
there's a paradox there that's the
i was just frightened i was fighting for
two reasons because that
do i really want to die do i really want
to merge with the absolute or god
do i really want to see my true nature
which is why we run away from the
inward here's the quote that we can put
out everything that we do in life
as separate individuals is to avoid the
nothingness that you are is to avoid
this
this is nothingness which is why it's
also everything and then i was like
everything that i knew and experienced
throughout my whole lifetime and from
everybody
is in there that's the potentiality of
unmanifested which is the same as the
manifested
is this is this set everything we do in
life is to avoid nothingness
and nothingness that we are that we are
i mean
i was like i could just stop meditating
and then just you know go back to my
life or i could merge with this thing
so this thing it's almost like the
screen the the let's call it the screen
the screen of god
and then this is the screen of frank
which is already detaching itself from
itself
that's why the screen of god could
appear uh
in the perception of the screen of frank
but then they actually the same thing
so i was like once i realized that man i
have to do this i don't know when i made
another chance because
after like 10 days of meditation for 12
hours i you know this thing came up i
was like
you know i don't know why i'm gonna get
another chance to
getting die and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and then
i was like i blanked out i i thought i
could enter it
that was my original um initial thought
i was like i thought i could enter it
and go into econo
and experience god unity or whatever but
then that wasn't the case
i totally blinked out and that is the
the the succession right there
in the succession there's just nothing
it's almost like a few friends that's
taken away from the the cinema of your
life if there's still something it's not
it
so i completely blanked out there was no
experience at all there's not even an
experience of nothing or god nothing
which is almost like i fell asleep but
in a very high concentrated state
that's death right there and then i came
back in
and then i just sort of got popped out
of the god
of the godhead um and then there was
this like whole body bliss and
ever since after that i knew i entered
stream entry the first
stage of awakening according to a
theravada buddhist tradition
now i used to pretty attached to those
past but not anymore but just
in accordance with the theravada
tradition after that event was when
everything just goes
exponentially faster and faster and then
my perception after that i just shifted
i could feel like you know my perception
was panoramic 360. but it was still a
bubble that where
i still haven't broken through awareness
yet so at the time i was like
my head was my head got really big but
there was still a distortion
there was still the awareness i could
still sense a bubble so that bubble has
to expand expand expand and the
character has to continue to strengthen
the secrets to continue
string strength until the secret is
nothing and there's no even bubble
awareness there's not even consciousness
there's no way that the self can hide
not even in awareness not even
consciousness not even nothing
so that was my first reaction when i saw
that picture you brought me back the
memory of
entering stream entry and then uh yeah
that that is the
the sculpture of the absolute
that is your that is a depiction even
though you can't really depict what your
true nature is
um and by the way
from the communion that i've had
as well validates also
as well as the communion from the people
that i've talked to
and featured on the show around their
realization
so that's really validating the many
paths
one end and also
that when you asked me a little bit ago
to also
unpack and describe what it is
to transcend even the all-inclusive
awareness itself
it is this it's becoming
the nothingness that we
ex that we purposely are
avoiding because the nature
is the perfect
of the eternal fire working away from
nothingness the whole thing is infinity
expressing itself away from
nothingness endlessly fractaling just
like
this image the sculpture of god is
also in many ways
it is as we had when we first
pulled up the program
it is like you see when you look up
our homies over at maths town
these guys are the homies because
it really is this this is what we're
talking about
we're talking about stuff like this this
being it this being infinity endlessly
fractaling expressing itself as your
unique costume endlessly your costume
frank's costume the eight billion
costumes right now
the next creation that has different
vehicles that has a different
civilization that has a different
history that has a different rock
orbiting a star
that doesn't even have rocks orbiting
stars that doesn't even have nervous
systems it doesn't even have dna
it has all this different you can never
come to the end
and you will always be something new you
will always be something
unique yet you're also nothingness yes
yes yeah and so so get used to
you know benoit mandelbrot has
this incredible math that then we turn
into the visualization that is as close
as we can right now and frank and i are
aiming to collaborate on
creating visuals that even help us
recognize
not only this but also this specific
expression
of our creation and then going beyond
that as well
and so just you know tap into stuff like
this
and it will uh enable you like we talk
about this a lot on the show but
if you really just do simple stuff like
if you contemplate simple words
like contemplate here's here's a very
short
list you have
the accommodation that which gives rise
fractals of infinity is the
inconceivable infamous
inevitable that gives rise even to those
to that ima to the animation
right yeah exactly you are
that which inevitably gives rise to this
infinite possibility yes yes correct and
that's why when you have people like
nisar godzilla maharaja
he would endlessly he would refuse
whenever there would be any games of
identity being played he would say
you are that and siddhara meshwar would
also
say this who is his guru that as you
think
so you are so you're going to play the
game of identity you're going to be your
onion layers
i'm going to only be the source of
infinite possibility that's my nature
that's who i am that's what this is
and so i am that and i am not what you
think
is this body and so this form and so
when you contemplate even
intellectually intellectually as frank
indicated
you can work your way like gym
repetitions up to the realize
to experience and to really into
realization
because these are your words when you
look up things like infinity when you
look up things like eternity when you
look up things like automata
and recursion what you realize is that
we are
that these are the words that we are
when you look at the way that a cell
hits a cell checkpoint
and then undergoes mitosis when you look
at
the way that two humans come together
and reproduce to make a human which then
finds another human to reproduce make a
human
just like the oak tree drops an acorn
that then makes more oak trees that drop
more acorns it's
just recursion it's atomic tug go to the
big bang
poof and what happens automata self
making
self producing endlessly and guess what
cycle again
as sir roger penrose who won the nobel
prize in physics in 2020 says
that where we are going is where we came
from
we it's a cyclic cosmology even the
world's leading
physicists themselves which is really
exciting for the synthesis of science
and spirituality
yeah what were we talking about earlier
about the uh the symbols that the logos
and the animation that you showed us
with the the loop in the background
itself thing
yes that doesn't just apply to space
that also
applies to time because time and space
are the same fabric einstein said that
himself
um is that the past and the future and
the present are just persistent
illusions
even he understood that without the
direct experience of it just through
equations
so that infinite loop that i always tell
people i always like try to illustrate
to people
right snake biting its own tail the
universe eating itself or this picture
whatever
that also applies to time because if you
think about it
that loop if you visualize that loop as
a four-dimensional space-time
whatever is the case when you were born
until you die is the case there is some
okay on the spiritual path sometimes i
tell people whatever isn't there since
the beginning of your birth until you
die or even before your birth because
it's gonna be experienced by other
people
or even after you die isn't it so if you
loop that thing from the beginning of
your birth
whatever it is that stays constant since
the beginning of your birth
until until the moment of now until the
moment you die
there's a loop and within this loop
forms sort of shape-shift inside it so
it's almost like
in this if you abide in this eternal
loop it
almost feels like whenever you think
about the past it's the same as thinking
about the future
the past memory it really feels like it
hasn't happened because the new group
everything is happening but nothing's
happening when you think about the
future
it seems like either it could already be
passed or it doesn't even exist so it's
like the past and the fusion of prison
are loses meaning the sequential events
of past
your president loses meaning and even
the now even the power of now
is empty because there really is no now
because now is co-dependent
rising through past and future yeah
never came
the past sorry if the i got [ __ ] up
the class never came
that is kind of true okay let's go back
to the conventional level for a little
bit if the future will never come
and if the past already dead it will
never you know arise again
then the future cannot be sorry the
president cannot be said to be exist
either because they're called
immediately rising
because you can still suffer in the in
the power of now actually
you free up a lot you free up a lot of
stuff in the now
if you only abide in the now free up a
lot of stuff but in fact if you take now
to be the new ground a new static thing
would just be like oh this only the now
you can still suffer in the now but when
deconstructing it now it's almost like
deconstructing awareness
see the self is not the cheeky con that
it could abide it could
hide itself in awareness and same thing
as hiding itself in the power of now
but once constructed dissolve even
awareness when the self completely
dissolves when there's nothing nowhere
to hide when it's just free-falling
uh even the now ceases to be meaningful
because the now and awareness almost
simultaneously exists one from the
perspective of space
and the other from the perspective of
time
once that last speck of self is
dissolved there's no
now to abiding there's no awareness to
find solace in
it's just inconceivable
at the same time it's so simple it's so
ordinary and that is why it's
ordinary the more ordinary something is
the more normal something is the more
magnificent and more divine something is